don't you avoid
don't they
the internet is to human interaction as
Pringles are two potatoes closeness and
companionship are ground up into an
unrecognizable slurry then artificially
reconstituted into a mockery of their
natural form we're social creatures but
we isolate ourselves into cubicles and
small rooms writhing with power strips
and then we go online and try and
recreate the very communities that we're
actively avoiding I myself have many
friends that I've never met but I care
about them at least enough to say post
bail if they were arrested and assuming
the jailhouse takes paypal but here's
one thing that I'm never going to say
wow this party is so great it's almost
as cool as an Internet message board I'm
not capable of that level of sarcasm and
I'm a professional SAR cast with this in
mind it's it's kind of strange than I
end up getting involved in social
networking sites so often I mean social
networking the term itself glistens with
utilitarian smarm if you're the sort of
person who goes home from a shindig and
org Allah to pick up more business cards
to pass out well congratulations you're
a social networker leave me alone I have
a long-standing principle of being very
skeptical of any verb form that doesn't
easily take to the preterite like what
were you doing last night oh I was
social networking I was I was networking
socially I found myself in a social
situation and what do you know i
networked it if you can't substitute
caroused or reveled or in a pinch hobnob
it's not the sort of social that I want
to be networking in the first place
nonetheless I feel obligated to keep up
with cutting-edge online communication
sites which basically means I sign up
for whatever Jason Kottke tells me to
and that's how I got involved with
twitter twitter takes by pringles
analogy to its logical conclusion it's
this sort of microblogging site where
each entry is limited to 140 characters
so you open it up and you end up with
this vertical stack of artificially
flavored reconstituted bite-sized
communication snacks it's it's very
compelling and yet at the same time
staunchly unfulfilling by
it leaves you with the feeling that yes
maybe just one more will quell the
roiling ennui within like an elderly
widow keeping the television on for some
semblance of company I often leave a
Twitter window open while working and
then over the day I learned such vital
facts is Jonathan Coulton is riding in a
minivan CAD Wil Wheaton likes the new
b-52s album and Jason kotsky himself and
I'm quoting here is having a really
crappy morning I think one reason that
Twitter remains so unsatisfying is that
it asks what may be the most boring
question possible what are you doing if
you call up a friend in your eyes k what
have you been up to lately what's new
what's exciting you might get an
interesting answer but if you call them
up and say what are you doing right now
Oh watching TV doing some laundry
talking to you that's because if they
were doing something interesting like
seducing a Nobel Prize laureate or
rescuing a baby from a burning submarine
they wouldn't have answered the phone
and it's a good bet that they wouldn't
be sending messages out to the internet
either furthermore the 140 character
limit while discouraging this sort of
lengthy self-indulgent maxi musings the
characterized livejournal seems well not
really enough for really interesting
postings while still being way too much
for boring postings take for example
something boring I just broke one of my
shoelaces I need to buy another one well
too I guess that's what 80 characters
well it's about 70 too long a post like
that can safely be truncated too I still
exist now let's take something exciting
hey I'm at six flags it's robot day I'm
standing in the Bourbon bot line and I'm
right behind Jeanne Tripplehorn she just
asked me if I have any massage oil in my
insufficient now I contribute to Twitter
I contribute my own tweets that's what
they call them I'm not a tweet leech
that's not what they call it but they
should what do I write about well hash
browns mostly whenever I make a batch of
hash browns I come up and I
twitter how it went I am being
completely serious about this I must be
stopped